Now we'll turn to another interesting problem where the choice of approach
is crucial for good performance.
This is the problem of graph traversal,
specifically, a breadth-first traversal of a graph.
So let's define the terms that we're using here.
A graph consists of a set of vertices and edges that connect these vertices.
So in this picture vertices are blue circles, edges are green lines.
Some graphs might be sparse with few edges per vertex,
some might be dense and have lots of edges per vertex.
Large graphs, very large graphs, are an interesting recent topic of study.
The World Wide Web, for instance, can be considered a graph,
with pages as vertices and links between pages as edges.
Or the social network of Facebook, Google, or Twitter
is a graph where people are vertices and friendships are links.
These companies would like to use this social graph to, say,
suggest friends you might know based on the friends you already have.
And making these suggestions depends on analyzing the graph.
A traversal involves visiting all the nodes in the graph.
Web crawlers must traverse the Web to catalog it for searching.
How do they make sure they visit each web page once and only once?
A traversal of the web graph will allow them to do that.
Now, there's 2 approaches to traversing a graph,
called depth-first traversal and breadth-first traversal.
And so this picture is going to help us show the differences.
In a depth-first traversal we begin at a particular node.
So we're going to pick this one in the middle and we're going to label it 0.
We're going to pick a neighbor we haven't visited yet, let's say this one here,
and then we're going to do a depth-first traversal from that node.
So we're going to continue down the chain, label this one, and so on.
If we run out of unvisited neighbors, such as here,
we pop back to a previously visited node and continue.
Well, we don't have any neighbors here either, so we might pop back here.
And now we're going to continue with our other unvisited neighbors.
So we might come here next. We don't have any more.
We pop back up. We might come here next, 4, 5, 6, pop all the way back up here.
Now we might come down to this one here, move here, pop back up, and then go 9 and 10,
eventually come back up to our original route node.
We decide that there are no more unvisited neighbors and then we complete.
In a breadth-first traversal we're going to begin with a node just as we did as in a DFS,
and we're going to pick the same starting node,
but now we're going to have a different algorithm.
So once we're at a particular node and we're running a breadth-first traversal,
what we're going to do is immediately visit all the neighbors that are 1 hop away
before we do any descent at all.
So first we're going to visit all the neighbors that are 1 hop away.
Only then will we start to descend farther past any of these neighbors.
So now we'll take the first one of these
and we will visit all of its unvisited numbers that are 1 hop away.
Well, now we're complete here, so now we're going to go to number 2.
We're going to do a traversal here, we're complete there.
We come back out to number 3. We continue to traverse here.
So we go 1 hop away and then pop back up. Now we go to number 4.
What are the ones that are 1 hop away from number 4?
Now we're at 8 and so on.
One thing you can notice here is that we have a structure that we call a frontier
that forms the boundary between all the nodes that we've already visited
and all the nodes that we haven't visited.
And we see that as we continue our traversal
that's just going to expand the frontier out and out and out again.
So we'll complete this by going to number 9 and then eventually to number 10.
Now, which one of these is better?
Well, it depends on the problem, the structure of the graph, what you're looking for,
if you're able to make good decisions about which way to go next.
Generally, people will say that DFS requires less state,
less temporary storage to run.
But BFS, on the other hand, exposes more parallelism during the traversal,
and specifically, because of this parallelism quality,
today we're going to look at how to do BFS on the GPU.